[Music]
now joe biden's reckless irresponsible
far-left immigration agenda is already
having a devastating impact at the u.s
southern border
our own lawrence jones is live he's in
new mexico tonight
speaking with the by the biden
administration halting border wall
construction
uh we also have a lot of guys that were
building that border that have all
gotten pink slips uh
lj a lot going on down there and a lot
of people pretty ticked off
a lot of folks ticked off sean good
evening uh
promises made promises kept that was the
mantra for
former president trump well when joe
biden got into office
he wanted to undo some of those promises
he used executive
orders first up border security
i had the opportunity to talk with
someone that has been impacted a fourth
generation
rancher i wanted to talk to him how it
impacted his family
and his community take a look
and you were promised a barrier to stop
illegals from coming on your property
well that was
that's been trump's motto through his
campaign and through his
administration they were going to build
a wall and it started in april of last
year and
and we were you know we were really
excited that this was happening and then
as soon as
president biden took office he pulled
the plug on this project and it came to
an immediate halt
what was it you feel
that told them that got them to this
position where they said that we didn't
need the wall anymore
did you guys complain about it were
other locals complaining about it
absolutely not everybody in our area is
in favor of this wall because they've
seen where it has worked
and that it does work the wall works the
wall works
this is all a politically driven agenda
this is and this is what's frustrating
to me is the biden administration
they're stopping the wall in my opinion
to try to hurt trump's legacy of
securing the border
when in reality all it is doing is
hurting the american people
now sean i had the opportunity to talk
with the border patrol today they
released a statement saying that
the suspension is real they are no
longer building the border wall but they
said they do plan on adding more
technology
and foot patrol on the ground but as you
see these things
in my hands right now these are called
footsies shun these are what illegals
put on their feet
to hide their trail as they're going
over these barriers
in different communities the rancher
found these on his property
these are some of the most high-tech uh
footsies i've ever seen so normally it's
bags
these are real stitching and it just
shows you the traffic that's out here on
the border sean
all right uh lj unbelievable and uh
you know all the people losing their
jobs too oh but they're gonna get jobs
in the
in the new green deal bill i don't know
doing what we'll find out
lj thank you